quand tu es gamin il ya une période tu
commences à comprendre les choses qui
t'entourent et en même temps tu
comprends pas tout non plus quand
j'étais petit je pensais que tout ce
qu'on voyait dans les films c'était vrai
tout était vrai et des adieux coupé
s'est pas fait des adieux mais fais ta
prière haché désolé mais on la refait à
tort suivant virez moi le canard et
actions et des adieux coupe est amer ah
non j'ai encore où je suis désolé je
suis désolé en plus à la blette la
boulette
quand j'étais petit je croyais que si je
louche est et qu'il y avait du vent je
pouvais rester bloqué comme ça toute ma
vie c'est ce qu'on m'avait raconté du
coup j'ai du coup j'ai cru et hubert
huberte à vue jeudi j'arrive à but non
non je suis resté comme ça toute ma vie
on fait quoi du coup on va en boîte je
drague et des mines est quand j'étais
petit je croyais que le sel provenaient
des baleines à cause du sel la baleine
voilà quand j'étais petit je regardais
les publicités pour les serviettes
hygiéniques et la télé et je comprenais
pas à quoi ça servait et quand je
demandais à ma mère elle me répondait
c'est un truc de fille tu comprendras
quand tu seras plus grands alors du coup
je croyais que
mais maman qu'est ce que tu fais tu ne
regardes les filles verser du liquide
bleu sur des serviettes hygiéniques en
secret même chose pour les tampons un
jeu je comprenais pas l'utilité
c'est très très pratique un jeu je dors
pas oui je dors beaucoup mieux la nuit
non non vraiment c'est un régal
j'insiste c'est très bien très bonne
idée les fier quand j'étais petit on m'a
raconté que si je faisais pipi dans la
piscine municipale
mon pipe il allait devenir d'une couleur
genre rouge ou bleu et tout le monde le
verraient mais c'est absolument pas vrai
tu peux pisser dans la piscine personne
ne verra ce message est approuvée par
l'association des gens dégueulasse quand
j'étais petit je pensais que quand je
joue à la super nintendo contre
l'ordinateur
en fait je jouais contre quelqu'un
ailleurs qu'ils étaient payés pour ça
l'heure de la pause déj ok j'arrive
c'est bon je and on and on le petit
cyprien veut en faire une partie quand
j'étais petit je croyais que l'animateur
de questions pour un champion
jouer aussi dans batman top à l'âge de 6
ans je regarde tous les jours question
pour un champion dans l'espoir de voir
batman à la place du présentateur je
suis je suis je suis complètement
stupide bonne réponse je suis
complètement stupide quand j'étais petit
je pensais que avant il ya très
longtemps
la vie était en noir et blanc ça
voudrait donc dire que à une époque les
genres et vécu le passage à la couleur
pas mal sympa ton t-shirt green à merci
mais j'ai failli prendre en gris clair
mais je les prie en gris moyen aux
mondiaux c'est quoi ça
conclusion quand j'étais petit j'étais
vraiment très con oh le con âge et et e
bay ah oui au fait quand j'étais petit
je ressemblais à ça
et toi tu croyais à quoi quand tu étais
petit 1 allez dis moi tout
quelle mère fermé de l'asie occidentale
est bordée par la jordanie est par
israël
ce la mer noire dans quelle mère faisons
partie de l'océan arctique bord de la
sibérie fram et loire la merde
quelle mère située entre l'arabie et
l'afrique est relié à la méditerranée
par le canal de suez sur la mer noire
non là les rouches là au bord de quel
maire est située la station balnéaire de
yalta c'est la mer noire oui